salut ça va bah ouais ça va ça fait
longtemps
le face caméra sur youtube clotilde ou
je ne sais pas à la dernière fois que je
suis venu en face caméra sur youtube
c'était il ya on va aborder un sujet
purement archéo et en plus un peu
mystérieuse qui est pas forcément le
style de la chaîne 1 si vous n'êtes pas
trop le truc sur lequel je sorte
habituellement mais là en l'occurrence
bas c'est un sujet les invasions donc
des peuples de la mer qui pourraient
archéologue et pas très clair et on va
expliquer pourquoi toujours avec des
exemples de la nuance voilà on va pas
avoir à changer il va pas changer le
style non plus alors le fond change oui
alors sauf pour ceux qui sont sur
instagram et qu'ils reconnaissent un
petit peu le fond de nos de nos lives de
cette année donc ceux qui ne
reconnaissent pas d'acheter parce que
vous faites venait sur instagram espaces
il se passe plein de trucs on est on est
bien on est bien là bas voilà donc je
vous propose pour être en en lien avec
le thème là qui nous qui nous guide
aujourd'hui peuples de la mer avait
coûté venez déferlé sur le compte
instagram fait une fête une invasion
voilà je serais très heureuse
[Musique]
d'habitude pour les périodes anciennes
comme celles dont on va parler
les historiens n'ont pas de date à se
mettre sous la dent les évolutions sont
lentes et floue les période délimitée à
la louche
il existe cependant une exception c'est
la fin de l'âge du bronze dans les
années 11 181 la quasi totalité des
grandes cités de méditerranée orientale
s'effondre subitement sous les coups
d'envahisseurs mystérieux le monde grec
l'empiré hittite en turquie actuelle
ainsi que la cote du proche orient alors
sous domination égyptienne en font les
frais les palettes brûlent les cités se
vident de leurs habitants et des
civilisations disparaissent c'est la fin
brutale d'une époque flamboyante la fin
de l'âge du bronze
cet épisode a durablement changer le
destin de la région modifiant les
équilibres démographiques rayant de la
carte de brillantes civilisations et
dopant le développement d'autres
cultures pour des siècles à venir
tout ça à cause d'une invasion en tout
cas c'est ce qu'on a longtemps pensé la
réalité historique et on va le voir plus
complexe le seul empire de méditerranée
orientale qui ait survécu à ce
cataclysme et l'egypte superpuissance
centré sur le nil et sa vallée à
l'insolente fertilité oui j'ai un auteur
qui s'appelle lucapa cote & it e pont
des phrases comme ça qui sonne super
bien ça va aller à à l'insolente
fertilité merci à lui plus peuplés mieux
organisés et peut-être plus chanceuses
l'egypte parvient à stopper cette
mystérieuse invasion en 11 177 avant
jésus-christ dans le delta du nil où les
envahisseurs avait débarqué ce sont donc
les égyptiens par le biais d'inscription
célébrant cette victoire qu'ils nomment
des responsables de cette invasion
les pelles et 7 decker accueillir ac à
callao [ __ ] on croit que je fais un
avc lie à l'épée les sept decker à
kagawa
chez calèche sardane d'aignan et welsh
tech et non toujours pas je me suis
encore planté c'est pas welch des ch
c'est wesh wesh
voilà on y retrouve des noms obscurs que
les archéologues sont regroupés sous
l'appellation de peuples de la mer
reste à savoir qui il était réellement
malgré quelques représentations de
prisonniers capturés lors de la bataille
en particulier sur le temple de ramsès
iii à médina tabou l'origine de ces
peuples restent incertaines aucun site
archéologique connu ne peut faire office
de point de départ de cette invasion
pour avoir une idée de leurs origines
historiens et archéologues se sont donc
attachés à remonter la piste des
destructions dans l'espoir d'obtenir une
chronologie et de retracer ainsi le
trajet de ces envahisseurs et il faut
avouer que le palmarès des peuples de la
mer est plutôt impressionnant miss aisne
pilos ted 3000 et à tous sa capitale de
l'empiré hittite tarse la riche cité
côtière d'ougarit tu ashdod chypre et la
côte de palestine toutes ces cités et
régions ont été dévastés dans les années
1990 on 180 avant jésus-christ
malheureusement la chronologie ne permet
pas de reconstituer un mouvement
uniforme d'ouest en est datée les
niveaux de destruction s'avère assez
compliqué pour ces périodes surtout si
on veut les dates et à la des prêts par
ailleurs ces peuples de la mer ne sort
pas de nulle part
les égyptiens au siècle précédent les
accusés de faits de piraterie
ils n'ont donc pas fait irruption
brutalement en méditerranée orientale
puisque il fréquentait déjà ses côtes
mais ils ont en revanche montré beaucoup
plus de férocité en ce début du 12e
siècle avant notre ère au point d'être
accusé de détruire des cités entières
il a par les reliefs égyptiens du temple
de ramsès iii
il a d'autres documents écrits qui
témoigne de cette invasion
il s'agit de lettres échangées par les
souverains douga rites et dallas chiyah
sans doute l'ancien nom de chypre pour
coordonner leur réponse militaire face
aux envahisseurs
certains textes laissent penser qu'une
partie de la population locale s'est
même allié au nouveau venu et s'est
révolté contre le pouvoir en place mais
ça j'en reparlerai tout à l'heure à
parler destruction des villes les
archéologues peuvent aussi deviner les
épisodes d'invasion grâce à l'apparition
de nouveaux objets et traditions sur les
sites qu'ils fouillent un changement
rapide dans les manières de construire
ou de décorer les poteries indique alors
que la population a changé ou au moins
que le pouvoir a été remplacé et à cette
époque on constate justement de
nouvelles pratiques alimentaires et
techniques dans le travail du textile en
méditerranée orientale ce qui fait
vraiment penser à une vague
de peuplement découlant d'invasion
certains de ces peuples de la mer
seraient donc restés sur place
d'ailleurs parmi les peuples cité par
les égyptiens figurent les et les sept
dont la sonorité est très voisines de la
palestine et des philistins philistins
qui sont évoqués notamment dans les
récits bibliques puisqu'ils se sont
affrontés aux hébreux par la suite
on aurait donc là un peuple installer
durablement après l'invasion donnant
même son nom à la région qu'ils
colonisent la palestine ce n'est pas
improbable quand on pense que la france
tient elle aussi son nom dans leicester
originaire germany d'autres n'ont eux
semblent nous renseigner plus tôt sur
l'origine des envahisseurs et non sur
leur point de chute
les accueils awa évoque les inquiète
autrement dit les grecs l'échec et
laisse toujours en se fiant aux
sonorités serait rapproché des siciliens
et les chars dan des habitants de la
sardaigne
voilà vous avez suivi à en croire les
noms cités par les égyptiens on verrait
donc se dessiner un mouvement important
de populations venues de l'ouest et
déferlant sur le monde oriental
mais si on y voit un peu plus clair
quant à leur origine le motif de cette
invasion reste inconnu des archéologues
ont proposé de trouver cette explication
dans une sorte d'effet boule de neige
d'invasion
ce phénomène est connu pour le moyen-âge
par exemple les uns ou les mongols en
déferlant sur l'asie et l'europe
on poussait de vente eu d'autres peuples
qui fuyaient la destruction et qu'ils se
mettent eux aussi à envahir d'autres
régions or on trouve dans les mythes
grecs sur les âges obscurs des récits
d'une invasion d'orienne c'est à dire en
provenance du nord de la grèce
continentale les balkans pour certains
chercheurs on aurait donc peut-être à
faire à un mouvement d'invasion plus
profond dont les peuples de la mer ne
serait finalement que l'aboutissement
cet effet boule de neige ne fournit
malheureusement pas une explication
parfaite notamment ce qui concerne la
sicile et la sardaigne ou encore
pourquoi la population locale se serait
alliée aux envahisseurs
et puis d'ailleurs pour l'instant de
telles preuves d'une invasion venue du
nord de la grèce sont introuvables
aucune nouveauté suffisamment brutale en
la culture matérielle ne permet de
conclure une population aurait déferlé
avec armes et bagages sur le monde grec
ou anatolien à la fin de l'âge du bronze
il ya bien d'autres récits qui ne sont
pas revenues de ses adjointes à
l'illiade et l'odyssée
ils prennent justement place dans cette
chronologie d'une 12e
siècle avant notre ère mais s'il
décrivent la destruction de la ville de
troyes qui on l'a vu a bien été ravagée
par cette vague d'invasion il reste
malheureusement silencieux sur les
autres événements
on va donc explorer d'autres hypothèses
pour expliquer l'effondrement de la
méditerranée orientale
à la fin de l'âge du bronze l'historien
américain eric klein dans son livre 11
177 avant jésus-christ le jour où la
civilisation s'est effondré recense au
moins quatre autres causes majeures
possible alors il le fait en pas moins
de 200 pages extrêmement répétitives ou
qui parlent kieran ont d'autres choses
donc si ça vous dérange pas on va
synthétiser un peu semble en effet que
la grèce ait connu entre 225 et 11 175
avant jésus-christ une série de séismes
importants que les archéologues
reconnaissent à des stigmates
caractéristiques de destruction des murs
et colonnes effondrée ainsi que des
fissures sur de nombreux sites tels que
miss aisne tyrant pilot sous thèmes
semblent indiquer une très forte
activité sismique à cette époque
toutefois et malgré les dommages
importants qu'ils ont causé ces
tremblements de terre ne peuvent pas
expliquer à eux seuls des migrations de
grande ampleur et l'effondrement de
civilisation entière
[Musique]
alors de nombreux chercheurs ont proposé
qu'un épisode de sécheresse en
méditerranée orientale
et puis entraîné une famine et motivé le
départ de population on dispose en effet
de nombreux textes de l'empiré hittite
en turquie actuelle qui demande aux
égyptiens de le renvoyer leurs excédents
de céréales les hittites en manquer
régulièrement et un épisode de
sécheresse à celle on aurait pu
transformer cette précarité alimentaire
en famine généralisée
les études sur les restes fossiles de
pollen piégés dans les sédiments de
toute la région confirme d'ailleurs un
épisode de sécheresse important aux
dates qui nous intéresse alors au point
de pousser au départ des milliers de
personnes massées difficile à dire
[Musique]
les destructions constatées sur de
nombreux palais grecque et sur plusieurs
sites du proche orient ont pu être causé
par des révoltes des habitants plusieurs
hypothèses ont été imaginés à ce sujet
une trop grande pression fiscale des
émeutes pour obtenir des vivres dans un
contexte de famille
là encore difficile d'imaginer qu'une
insurrection puisse conduire à l'abandon
pur et simple d'une cité les cités en
proie aux difficultés évoquées jusqu'à
maintenant aurait selon cette théorie
davantage succombé à la rupture des
relations commerciales qui aurait suivi
les invasions et autres révoltes la
méditerranée orientale il ya 3000 ans
était un espace parcourue par de
nombreux navires marchands et les sites
et possédaient des économies très
interdépendantes
la rupture d'approvisionnement notamment
en céréales et en produits de luxe comme
le bronze aurait pu avoir des
conséquences tragiques sur les royaumes
s'il ya bien eu une invasion des peuples
de la mer on le voit elle ne peut pas
porter seuls la responsabilité de cet
effondrement
toutes les causes que nous avons
énumérées ont pu se produire à plusieurs
reprises au deuxième millénaire avant
jésus-christ les tremblements de terre
tout comme les sécheresses et épisodes
de famine était fréquent les révoltes
les guerres et les crises économiques
nous le savons même aujourd'hui se
produisent régulièrement pour autant il
n'entraîne pas systématiquement
d'effondrement de civilisation mais en
ce sens 80 avant jésus-christ ces
différents événements ont probablement
eu lieu
tous en même temps ou presque
l'historien eric klein parle pour
caractériser ce moment de perfect storm
expression anglaise qu'on pourrait
traduire par un parfait désastre
résultat d'une conjonction d'accidents
qui s'ils sont surmontables
individuellement deviennent tous
ensemble un cataclysme dévastateur comme
souvent pour expliquer des phénomènes
complexes
on peut pas se contenter d'une
explication unique j'avais déjà évoqué
pour parler de la disparition des mayas
une conjugaison de facteurs un peu
similaire la fin de l'âge du bronze en
méditerranée orientale
c'est donc une sorte d'effet domino sans
qu'il soit possible de définir
véritablement une cause première
l'effondrement se serait propagé parce
que les royaumes était trop dépendants
les uns des autres avec leur pouvoir
très centralisé et des circuits
économiques extrêmement dépendant des
commandes royales
c'était en réalité des constructions
fragiles et la chute a pu être très
rapide parfaits boucs émissaires les
peuples de la mer ne sont que la partie
émergée de ce parfait désastre
l'événement le plus visible pour les
archéologues et on suppose désormais que
leur invasion n'a pas été aussi soudaine
et violente qu'on le disait navigateurs
présents depuis plusieurs siècles dans
la région on pense aujourd'hui qu'ils
ont migré vers l'est pendant plusieurs
décennies fuyards réfugiés climatiques
envahisseurs colons peut-être tout en
même temps
le mystère reste entier c'est la fin de
cet épisode merci beaucoup de l'avoir
regardé s'il vous a plu mettez un like
vous pouvez le partager également si
vous avez des question j'ai bien
conscience que c'est un sujet assez
dense gelé beaucoup beaucoup synthétiser
utiliser les commentaires c'est fait
pour ça je répondrai à vos questions sur
ce sujet et puis bah écoutez d'ici la
prochaine vidéo qui arrivera du sud
quelques semaines encore sur un sujet
requis au dont j'ai très hâte de vous
parler et bien vous pouvez me rejoindre
sur les réseaux sociaux notamment
instagram et tik tok et puis si vous le
pouvez vous pouvez soutenir la chaîne le
travail qui est fait sur cette chaîne
sur tipis et sur youtube
je vous embrasse et je vous dis à la
prochaine c'est lui
non
[Musique]